the jurgen experience the
the and the other thing is like you're
going to become a conservative well then
well then okay now you're tribal
can't you just be someone who's
politically homeless like why do you
have to be on this other side now
now you have to like you know say i'm a
god-fearing christian and
donald trump was brought here by jesus i
met trump this past weekend
he has regular-sized hands by the way
they're not tiny the media they're full
of [ __ ] you sure he wasn't wearing fake
heads he might have been wearing fake
hands
he's a clever very slapstick yeah put on
his face
where'd you meet him at the ufc what was
he like
came over to me when i was working i had
my headphones on and uh i said hey how
you doing man nice to meet you shook his
hand
and uh got a video of it it's kind of
hilarious
uh he's like you do tremendous job
amazing job good job
and then he said that daniel cormier was
next to me who was a former light
heavyweight champion and the former
heavyweight champion goes i do not want
to fight this guy i do not want to fight
this question
i should have got a selfie with him i
should have missed opportunity
what are you gonna do it was weird it
was very weird when he walked in though
i'm telling you man
they cheered the [ __ ] out of him oh he
has like a [ __ ]
um some dead enders who really want to
see him be president again one way or
another
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience